Natasha Bedingfield has become one of the most popular female singers in the last few years.
She spent all of 2008 on tour promoting her latest CD, Pocketful of Sunshine.
Natasha found love last year when she became engaged to California businessman Matt Robinson.
He stole my heart,...
...you know, I was holding out.
...and my first song was called Single.
It was about being solo and proud of it, and independent,...
...and I really didn't just fall for any person, really,...
...but yeah, he won my heart.
With three Top 10 Billboard Chart singles from her latest album,...
...Natasha says, the thrill starts before the record is even released.
It's amazing when you are in the studio and you get that excitement,...
...you feel like a kind of buzz,...
...and you kinda want to test it out because that's what the next stage really is.
You might like something, but do other people like it?
You know, when someone comes up to me and goes,..
...this is our song or my song, you know. That's very special.
Not only is Natasha expanding as a performer,...
...her new CD also demonstrates her songwriting ability.